I'm not gonna cost you a dime oh you
sons of [ __ ] so if there's one thing
I've learned during my burger journey
it's that a burger isn't just well a
burger I'm so ready
I'm so excited veggie burgers aren't
just for vegetarians I think at first it
can stir up regional pride I feel like
I'm about to go on a Vision Quest I see
so many wonderful things this is gonna
be a huge trend in Los Angeles from
pastrami's team inspire creativity in
international birds or and we don't need
to travel far just getting really most
oh right now I'm one of the most amazing
burgers oh my I love you all
Oh can this be considered a dumpling
this would be the most meaty dumpling
I've ever if you're gonna make a good
sushi you got make a good burger to even
push us to our limits a lot of people
say thanks chef for good job chef and
I'm like I didn't earn that one two
three
[Music]
so get ready for more burgers bigger
stars and new cities we're in Chicago
Illinois Vienna beef baby
is oozing juice light up the burger show
season four what's up burger fam it's
Alvin kai-lan from the burger show thank
you for your continual support make sure
you hit that like button smash that
subscribe button
turn on your notifications if not for me
for the burgers please and thank you